Narrator: A little more than
a week after the release
of "Avengers: Endgame," we are
treated to an all-new trailer
for "Spider-Man: Far From Home,"
and if you thought it was going to be
a quaint little movie, think again.
I'm talking about a multiverse.
Here's everything you might've missed
in the new "Spider-Man" trailer.
It starts with a spoiler
warning from actor Tom Holland.
He says if you haven't seen "Endgame,"
then don't watch the trailer.
We'll say the same.
The trailer starts with Peter Parker
talking to Happy Hogan.
He says he misses Iron Man.
Iron Man, of course, died in "Endgame"
when he snapped the
custom Infinity Gauntlet,
wiping Thanos and his
armies from the universe.
It seems that the whole world now knows
about Iron Man's sacrifice,
as Tony Stark is memorialized
in street art throughout the trailer
and what appears to be art-class drawings
in the background of this shot.
Happy tells Peter that
Tony sacrificed himself
because he knew Spider-Man
would be around.
This seems likely.
In "Endgame," Tony spots
this photo of him and Peter
before deciding to take a
stab at solving time travel
to reverse the Thanos snap.
Then, we cut to Peter
Parker fighting some goons
in his Iron Spider suit that Tony gave him
in "Avengers: Infinity War."
Peter: And this suit is
ridiculously intuitive, by the way.
Narrator: After Spider-Man
takes care of the goons,
a police officer asks
him if he's going to be
the next Iron Man.
This question seems like an important one.
Peter appears reluctant
to take on this burden.
Peter: Well, no, I don't have time.
I'm too busy doing your jobs.
Cops: Oh! What?
Narrator: Later in the trailer, he says,
"I'm just a friendly
neighborhood Spider-Man,"
but then, towards the end of
the trailer, Peter says...
The world needs the next Iron Man.
Narrator: And in the last trailer,
one of Peter's classmates says Mysterio
is like Iron Man and
Thor all rolled into one.
Seems like everyone is
trying to figure out
who can replace Tony Stark.
Spider-Man tells the cops
he's going on vacation.
We knew from the last trailer
that Spider-Man and his classmates
were going on a trip to Europe,
but turns out "Far From
Home" might take Peter
a lot further than just across the pond.
More on that in a bit.
Speaking of Peter's classmates,
a big question at the end of "Endgame" is,
who exactly from Peter's
high school got snapped away
for five years after Thanos' first snap?
It seems like the whole class
is still in high school five years later,
which suggests that they might've
missed out on those years
because Thanos snapped them all away,
but statistically, this
seems highly unlikely.
Hopefully, we'll get an answer
when the movie comes out.
Next, Happy and Peter have
a comical conversation.
Nick Fury tries to call Peter,
but Peter sends him straight to voicemail.
Nick and Peter probably
would've met at Tony's funeral
at the end of "Endgame."
Happy: You do not ghost Nick Fury!
Narrator: Notice the
Crusher Hogan fight sign
in the background of this scene.
This is a character in the
comics that Spider-Man fights
when he wants to test
out his brand-new powers.
We first see Crusher in the comics
in "Amazing Fantasy" No. 15.
Nick Fury finally gets
in contact with Peter,
meeting him in Europe,
but we knew that from the last trailer.
What we didn't know is that
Fury introduces Spider-Man
to Mr. Beck, or Quentin
Beck in the comics,
also known as Mysterio, and
here's where the magic happens.
Fury explains...
Nick: Beck is from Earth, just not ours.
Peter: You're saying there's a multiverse?
Narrator: There are an
unlimited number of Earths
in Marvel, which allows
for multiple possibilities.
Earth 616 is the main
universe from the comics,
while the MCU is referred
to as Earth 199,999.
Our Earth is designated Earth 1218,
and superheroes don't exist on it.
A multiverse opens up the possibilities
for stories like Peggy
Carter being injected
with Super Soldier Serum
and teams like the Exiles.
The Exiles are heroes,
all selected from different dimensions,
who hop around the multiverse,
trying to fix things
that may have gone bad on various Earths.
Fury also tells Peter
that the snap tore a hole
in our dimension, which begs
the question, which snap?
We've seen four Infinity
Stone snaps so far.
The first was in "Infinity War,"
which wiped out half of life.
Then in "Endgame," Thanos
snapped again to destroy the
stones. After the Avengers retrieve
the stones from the past,
the Hulk snaps to bring
everyone who disappeared back.
Then Tony snapped a fourth time
to rid the universe of Thanos.
The trailer conveniently gives us a reason
why Spider-Man is Fury's best hope.
Apparently, Thor is off-world
and Captain Marvel is simply...
Maria: Unavailable.
Narrator: Oh, hey, it's Agent Maria Hill.
We haven't seen her since
she was snapped away
by Thanos in "Infinity War."
Next up, the dry-humored
MJ has figured out
that Peter is Spider-Man,
which is sure to have a big
impact on their relationship.
In the Sam Raimi "Spider-Man" series,
when Mary Jane learned
Peter was Spider-Man,
things didn't end well, but
that was "Spider-Man 3,"
and we do not talk about "Spider-Man 3."
MJ here isn't Mary Jane,
but her knowing his secret
could still spell trouble.
MJ: I mean, it's kind of obvious.
Narrator: If Mysterio is
from another dimension,
it makes sense that the group of villains
that they appear to be
fighting are The Elementals,
four extra-dimensional
villains who each control
different elements: fire,
water, earth, and air.
But Mysterio in the comics
is the master of illusions,
and he's a total bad guy,
so it could be possible
that everything is an illusion
meant to make Mysterio
look like the hero in the absence
of one of Earth's
greatest heroes, Iron Man.
In the comics, Mysterio frames
Spider-Man as a criminal
using his powers of illusion.
Mysterio then tried to make himself
look like a hero by capturing Spidey.
We see Peter wearing these glasses,
which look an awful lot
like the glasses Tony wore.
When he takes them off,
Peter looks shocked.
These glasses could be a
filter that allow him to see
that there's no attack at all
and it's all an illusion
created by Mysterio.
Peter: Oh, my God.
Narrator: So what'd you
think of the trailer?
Are you excited for "Far From Home"?
Let us know in the comments.